all right here we go gonna let you know
right off the bat this video is brought
to you by squarespace the all-in-one
platform to build your online presence
and run your business we're gonna talk
about that a little later but first we
have ourselves an actual phase four mcu
movie not a show we've had shows movie
here we go
[Music]
so shang ching the legend of the ten
rings is the newest movie in the mcu and
a phase four movie oh wait black widow
i kind of forgot okay so this is the
first phase four movie that doesn't take
place you know in the past it's not a
flashback movie this one is actually
taking place uh pushing it forward and
as you all know i'm with names i
hope i pronounced his name correctly it
stars simuli as shang chi well or sean
and sean is kind of a man child he hangs
out with his friend played by aquafina
they go to late night karaoke and get
drunk on the weekends they're valet
parkers and they they don't really know
what to do with their lives you know
they're adults who haven't figured it
out totally relate then you find out
sean is shang chi and chongqi has a past
shang chi's got skills chong chi is
going to have to face his destiny by
facing his father and shang chi's badass
now i love simulu as chongqing in this
movie i loved him as a lead dude is very
charismatic very relatable you know
that's that's a hard thing to do here
dude is completely badass especially
from where he comes from but also hey
vulnerable relatable everyday guy that's
a tough balancing act he did a great job
in this movie also aquafina really does
work in this movie and the mcu as a
whole because the mcu is known for
bringing a lot of humor into their
movies sometimes to a fault sometimes to
a degree where you're like everybody is
funny in here and i don't feel like
they're being real and you feel like
you're in a comedy aquafina is that
she's that outlet they can funnel the
humor through and the comic relief
moments through well then again aquafina
isn't the only comic relief character
there is another support character in
this movie that's also there for comic
relief but for the dramatic moments that
are happening that involve her or she's
there for she doesn't crack a joke and
just ruin the moment i appreciate that
thank you for that there were sometimes
i was like uh oh and the comedic
character's gonna ruin it in three two
one
she didn't
well that's good news other movies in
general take notes on that and also love
tony lee young as the mandarin like
mandarin mulligan he should be called
alpha mandarin because he's the mandarin
before fake mandarins the mandarin
that's always been around but for the
sake of the mcu he is a mandarin
mulligan like they were like oh we did
that wrong oops here's the real one he's
always been around but i thought he was
an anomaly among mcu movies mcu movies
usually have forgettable villains that
exist just to have the good guys fight
someone because if you don't have a
villain for the good guys to fight you
don't have an mcu movie present purple
company accepted and loki let's be
honest the mcu is not known for their
villains making the movie it's just it's
happened in that anomaly form i thought
he was a standout among mcu villains it
concentrates a lot on him in fact part
of the heart of the movie has to do with
him he's a grieving widower and a father
that's
that's not unrelatable
i like the fact that they gave that to
the villain i'm glad they had a
threatening menacing intimidating
relatable villain and the martial arts
and this is where we get to the part in
this video where i talk about how my
favorite things in this movie are the
simplest things when the simple things
in this movie build to become over
complicated it's not as interesting to
me as the simple versions of those
things take the martial arts in this
movie for example in the first act into
some of the second act the martial arts
fights are just they're great they're
top-notch entertainment and it's a new
energy well
it's new for the mcu i'm not saying
martial arts like what's this in cinema
that's new not saying that i'm saying
for the mcu they've had to do something
new for a while now to inject it with
something that feels fresh and in this
movie you see that with the martial arts
fighting and you feel like they've
brought that to the mcu that first fight
on the bus you're like dude this is
actually this is pretty fresh stuff it
just through to what i like in martial
arts fights and martial arts movies some
slick martial arts great camera work
great choreography great cinematography
then the movie kind of it hits a lull
it hits some down time and i think a lot
of downtime and there's a pretty large
lull you know because it has to do with
family and i'd love to say i was super
attached to the family element i kind of
was i was attached to the mandarin's
perspective of it i don't know what that
says about me i guess when a movie gets
me attached to the villain's perspective
i guess that's the only perspective i
care about but after all that excitement
in the first act the second act you
definitely do feel like here's the down
time but then in the last act the
fighting comes back but it's not really
it's not the fighting i liked it's not
the fighting the movie pitch to me to
get attached to it's not really the
martial arts fighting anymore it's the
whole battlefield this big group versus
this big group and then you have other
elements and rock out with your rings
out in his ring on ring combat later on
in the movie when you start seeing some
extravagant weaponry and some cgi
weaponry and the martial arts kind of
took a back seat to the weaponry which
kind of took the forefront and the great
big cgi climax of this movie that took
center stage and kind of pushed some of
the characters into the background it
felt more mcu familiar there was even
build up with this masked character when
shang chi was training when he was a kid
you get the feeling this dude was a
total dick and there was no real payoff
with that tension i was like but why'd
you go the route you went i don't know i
mean the end looked great trying to keep
it vague but there was
some grand spectacle with the ending of
this movie and it did look good but
that's what i mean when i say there are
the simpler things in this movie which i
generally enjoyed most because the
concepts are simple and they were
kick-ass and execution but i felt like
all the craziness and the pomp and the
size of the climax of this movie i said
don't you be dirty in the comment
section stop it but you know what i mean
just like all the craziness that was
going down in the climax i felt
cheapened
the the built tension between the hero
and villain which was the father's son i
didn't feel the fulfillment i could have
felt if it just stuck with them oh shoot
i almost forgot about his sister
i almost forgot to talk about his sister
which does kind of make sense for me the
group the crew is essentially a shanghai
aquafina's character and chongqi's
sister and someone gives his sister a
weapon it says something along the lines
of it's time for you to come out from
the shadows or something like that i was
like
i don't know that they knew how true
that line was for the character because
this entire movie i felt like she was
definitely in his shadow just kind of
there but who knows maybe after a decade
of her being in mcu movies maybe then
she will finally get her own standalone
movie after dc finds success in it first
but only then this movie does have a
huge spiritual element which is a huge
part of the climax of this movie but i
felt like that got buried under the fact
that it was all there for a really good
looking action sequence regardless of
its flaws i still enjoyed the movie
which i guess makes sense because some
of the flaws in this movie are flaws
that have been in other mcu movies that
i've also enjoyed this movie does what
the mcu is known for doing which is to
provide you a reliably enjoyable big
blockbuster big budget cgi festive
enjoyment the movie i think has some
pacing issues as seen in the second act
when things just kind of not even kind
of very much slow down it's too long i
know i say that a lot but definitely you
could shave 15 minutes at least off of
this run time when the martial arts is
in the forefront it does feel like the
mcu has a new energy that it's going for
by the end of the movie you're like oh
it feels like an mcu movie because they
kind of fell into some of the mcu isms
that the mcu does flaws and all but
really if i had to peg the element that
made this movie for me i'd say other
than the martial arts when it was at the
forefront the mandarin i thought he was
a great villain i was pleasantly
surprised to see an mcu villain stand
out this much also i had an enjoyably
good time no alcohol required and as i
mentioned at the beginning of this video
this video is brought to you by
squarespace squarespace sells over 200
top-level domains you can find the
perfect name for your website buying a
domain from squarespace is simple no
hidden fees between that and the fact
that you can present videos from youtube
vimeo and animoto on your squarespace
site and i always dig the fact that
every design automatically comes with a
unique mobile experience that matches
the overall style of your website they
mean it when they say that the
all-in-one platform to build your online
presence and run your business so go to
squarespace.com for your free trial and
when you're ready to fulfill your
destiny that was a bit dramatic click
the link below go to squarespace.com
jeremy johns get yourself ten percent
off your first purchase of a website or
domain using promo code john and thank
you once again to squarespace for
sponsoring this video i do appreciate it
alright so chongqing the legend of the
ten rings well this review is a bit
early i'll say have you seen it what did
you think about it comment below let me
know for if you're watching this after
you've seen the movie in the meantime
what's a great martial arts flick that i
can sink my teeth into bring on your
recommendations whatever they are
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you